this is an observatory that's trying to
measure gravitational waves that are
distortions in space-time produced by
black holes out there in the universe we
measure these distortions with lasers
going back and forth between mirrors
measuring distances that will change
very very slightly due to this black
hole sending us messages from millions
of years away when the theory of
relativity was created it said that
black masses in general and black holes
because they're very compact distorts
space-time and produce these waves that
travel away at the speed of light we
want to measure here on earth what
happens when those black holes were born
when supernovas exploded when neutron
stars collided to form a black hole and
we want to detect the effect of those
astronomical events here on earth it's
something that has never been done
before we know gravitational waves exist
they are predicted by the theory of
relativity but we also have seen the
effects of gravitational waves from
systems that lose energy but we have
never measured them directly here not
that's the new window to the universe we
want to open